D
ENERGY ON ITS EFFORTS TO
DIVERSIFY ITS CURRENT
DEPENDENCE ON RUSSIA.
YESTERDAY FRANCE SIGNED A DEAL
WITH THE UNITED AIR EMIRATES
GUARANTEEING DIESEL SUPPLIES IN
THE SHORT TERM.
EARLIER I SPOKE WITH THE FRENCH
FINANCE MINISTER BRUNO MAYOR,
ASKING HOW BENEFICIAL THAT DEAL
WILL BE.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> IN THE SHORT TERM, BENEFITS
ARE OF COURSE SECURITY ON
ENERGY SUPPLY.
YOU KNOW THAT, AS I JUST SAID,
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEFINING NEW RESOURCES.
NEW PARTNERSHIPS.
YESTERDAY, THERE HAS BEEN THE
SIGNING OF A VERY IMPORTANT
AGREEMENT BETWEEN TOTAL AND A
KNOCK FOR DIESEL SUPPLY TO
FINANCE WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO
THE UAE FOR THEIR SUPPORT IN
THESE DIFFICULT TIMES.
WE ARE ALL TRYING TO FIND NEW
SUPPLY CHAINS.
THE UAE WILL CONTINUE TO PLAY A
KEY ROLE VIS-À-VIS FRANCE AND
ITS QUESTION OF ENERGY SUPPLY.
A NEW AGREEMENT SIGNED
YESTERDAY IS A VERY POSITIVE
SIGNAL FOR THE ENERGY SECURITY
FOR FRANCE.
>> HOW MUCH DIESEL ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT HERE?
AND THE NATIONAL OIL COMPANY OF
THE UAE --
>> I CANNOT GIVE YOU ANY
SPECIFIC FIGURE.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS IS A
MAJOR AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE UAE
AND FRANCE.
BETWEEN AT KNOCK AND TOTAL.
AND AGREEMENT BETWEEN MACRON
AND HIS HIGHNESS MUHAMMAD IN SO
HEED.
>> --
GAS SUPPLY CAME FROM RUSSIA,
MUCH OF THAT SUPPLY HAS ALREADY
BEEN DISRUPTED THROUGH NORTH
STREAM ONE.
YOU HAVE SAID YOU ARE PREPARING
FOR A TOTAL CUT OFF OF RUSSIAN
SUPPLIES.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU?
WOULD THAT MEAN FOR EUROPE AT A
TIME WHEN THESE EUROPEAN
ECONOMIES ARE UNDER SUCH
PRESSURE?
>> I WOULD NOT SAY WE ARE
CONCERNED, WE ARE VIGILANT.
WE ARE FULLY AWARE OF THE RISK
OF HAVING RUSSIA TURNING OFF
ALL GAS SUPPLY TO EUROPE.
WE HAVE TO BE PREPARED, WE HAVE
ALREADY TAKING ALL OF THE
NECESSARY DECISIONS FIRST OF
ALL, TO REINFORCE THE SUPPLY
CHAIN FORECAST FOR EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES, ESPECIALLY FOR
FRANCE.
WE ARE ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
DEFINING THE CONSEQUENCES ON
THE PRIVATE COMPANIES, ON
HOUSEHOLDS, ON ALL
ADMINISTRATIONS.
I THINK THAT A KEY THING IS TO
BE PREPARED IN THE CASE LETTER
AND PUTIN DECIDES TO C